aber die NATO war noch nie so eng
zusammengeschweißt wie heute Putin
bekommt genau das Gegenteil dessen was
er haben wollte als Konsequenz dessen
dass er die Ukraine einmarschiert ist
und diese Einigkeit bauen wir oft mit
der Europäischen Union und auch den G7
russland hat mit dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine fundamentale Werte unserer
Nachkriegsordnung gebrochen
wir rufen den russischen Präsidenten auf
endlich ein Waffenstillstand zu
vereinbaren und humanitäre Korridore zu
Versorgung und Evakuierung der
Zivilbevölkerung einzurichten die
russischen Truppen müssen aus der
Ukraine abziehen ja gleich drei Gipfel
heute in Brüssel herzlich willkommen
deshalb zu einem ZDF Spezial
US-Präsident Joe Biden ist in Europa und
es gab eine regelrechte show of force
das Westens und nato-treffen G7 und EU
Einigkeit soll demonstriert werden
angesichts der russischen Aggression die
größte sicherheitskrise einer Generation
sieht darin die NATO
über eine der wichtigsten Reisen eines
US-Präsidenten seit Jahren Claudia Beltz
der Präsident sieht sich in einem
wichtigen historischen Moment es geht
für ihn um nicht weniger als die
Verteidigung der Demokratie
überlebenswichtig dafür die
Geschlossenheit der westlichen
Demokratien neue Sanktionen gegen
hunderte russische Abgeordnete gegen
Rüstungsunternehmen mehr Nato-Soldaten
nach Osteuropa neue Milliarden für die
Ukraine ein kraftvolles Signal aus
Brüssel an Putin an China und an die
Zweifler im eigenen Land das oberste
Ziel
absolut Unity
absolute Einheit mit unseren NATO und
europäischen Alliierten in drei
Kernbereichen erstens die Ukraine mit
militärischer und humanitärer Hilfe zu
unterstützen zweitens die härtesten
Wirtschaftssanktionen aller Zeiten zu
verhängen drittens die östliche Flanke
unserer NATO Alliierten zu stärken wir
haben alle drei umgesetzt
zusammenstehen gegen den Aggressor das
ist Präsident beiden besonders wichtig
daran arbeitet er unermüdlich Putin darf
es nicht gelingen das Bündnis zu spalten
was aber wenn die Einheit auf eine Probe
gestellt wird wenn Russland Chemiewaffen
einsetzen würde einen waffenkonvoi für
die Ukraine Angriffe oder gar ein
natoland
ich glaube das einzige Risiko für ein
Scheitern wäre es wenn sich klare
Differenzen auftun würden es gab
verschiedene Vorschläge die nicht
umgesetzt wurden zum Beispiel der
Ukraine Mic Kampfjets aus Polen zu
überlassen
dann gibt es die die eine
Flugverbotszone durchsetzen wollen wenn
es sichtbare unterschiedliche Meinungen
gibt dann wäre das ein Rückschlag
für die USA ist dies auch der
uramerikanische Kampf des Guten gegen
das Böse beiden sieht sich in einem
systemkampf der chinesische Präsident hi
glaubt dass Demokratien zu behäbig sind
für unsere schnelle Zeit beiden ist
entschlossen das Gegenteil zu beweisen
deswegen steht hier viel auf dem Spiel
und die Tatsache dass China wenn auch
mit etwas Unbehagen bislang in diesem
Krieg an der Seite Russlands steht
bestärkt den Eindruck dass dies eine
historische Konfrontation ist zwischen
dem autokratischen Block Russland und
China und einer Gruppe von liberalen
Demokratien
die Zerstörung das Töten muss aufhören
Präsident beiden beschreitet einen
schmalen Grat der Krieg muss enden die
Demokratie muss ob siegen ohne das Putin
zum Äußersten getrieben wird und ohne
das US-Soldaten eingreifen müssen
zu Hause steht er unter Druck ist ein
ungeliebter Präsident die Ukraine ein
Thema wo eine Mehrheit hinter ihm steht
politische Gegner kritisieren ihn als zu
zögerlich
ich glaube Präsident beiden hat einen
großen Fehler gemacht indem er die
Möglichkeit US-Truppen einzusetzen
ausgeschlossen hat dafür hat er nichts
bekommen es war ein unerzwungener Fehler
er hätte einfach sagen können alle
Optionen liegen auf dem Tisch und Putin
Rätseln lassen worin die Vieldeutigkeit
liegt und die Sanktionen kamen erst nach
der Invasion und deswegen sieht man uns
als schwach die richtige Zeit um diese
Katastrophe zu verhindern wäre vor der
Invasion gewesen und wir haben versagt
für beiden geht es also um alles um
Frieden für die Menschen in der Ukraine
um die Demokratie in der Welt um die
globale Führungsrolle und darum sein
eigenes verwirrtes Land hinter sich zu
bringen und all das gelingt nur wenn er
jetzt und hier und in Zukunft eine
Allianz aufrechterhalten kann die sich
bei Sanktionen bei NATO einsetzen
gegenüber China einig ist
und in Berlin ist nur zugeschaltet die
Verteidigungsministerin guten Abend Frau
Lambrecht schönen guten Abend Frau
Pieper Frau Lambrecht Teil der Beratung
war heute dass die NATO die Ostflanke
gegen Russland stärken will was heißt
das dann konkret für die Bundeswehr wir
haben schon unterstützt wir haben schon
verstärkt beispielsweise unsere Truppe
in Litauen und wir werden uns jetzt auch
einbringen wenn es zusätzliche vier
battlegroups geben soll der NATO und wir
werden uns in das Slowakei engagieren
mit bis zu 700 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
die dort dann tätig sein werden die NATO
wird jetzt auch ihre Reaktionsfähigkeit
bei atomaren und chemischen Angriffen
erhöhen was heißt das denn genau und für
wie groß halten Sie denn die Gefahr dass
die NATO in den Krieg hineingezogen wird
wir müssen die Drohungen die von Putin
ausgestoßen werden sehr ernst nehmen
denn er hat gezeigt zu welcher
Brutalität er fähig ist durch diesen
Angriffskrieg den er führt gegen die
Ukraine mit all den mit dem all dem
Ausmaß an Leid für die Zivilbevölkerung
deswegen müssen wir uns aufstellen in
diesem Bereich vorbereitet sein für eine
solche für einen solchen Angriff aber es
muss auch immer wieder gerade auch
gegenüber Putin deutlich gemacht werden
dass das ein unfassbares ein
unfassbareskalation wäre unglaubliches
Leid bringen würde und deswegen die ganz
klare Aufforderung dass es dazu nicht
kommen darf
inzwischen schickt die Bundeswehr ja
nicht nur Schutzhelme sondern auch
Waffen in die Ukraine aber so heißt das
nicht so viele wie man angekündigt und
von der Ukraine erhofft woran hakt das
immer noch
wir unterstützen die Ukraine in
vielfältigster Weise sowohl in Bezug auf
Waffen aber auch in Bezug auf Ausrüstung
und auch andere Leistungen und das ist
wichtig denn das ist so beeindruckend zu
sehen mit welchem Mut mit welcher Kraft
hier auch gekämpft wird und deswegen
unterstützen wir in vielfältiger Weise
ich kann auch jede Forderung
nachvollziehen aber ich bitte auch
nachzuvollziehen dass wir in Bezug auf
die Ankündigung von dem was wir liefern
von dem was wir leisten dass wir da sehr
sehr verschwiegen damit umgehen denn
jede Lieferung soll auch dort ankommen
wo sie gebraucht wird nämlich in der
Ukraine und wir dürfen nicht riskieren
dass diese Transporte zur Zielscheibe
werden zur Zielscheibe von Putin der
über Aufklärung natürlich beobachtet wo
welche lieferungen erfolgen deswegen
noch mal wir unterstützen in
vielfältiger Weise wir überprüfen fort
während welche Möglichkeiten wir haben
nicht nur aus den Beständen der
Bundeswehr sondern auch durch Ankauf
diese Möglichkeit gibt es ja auch und
das werden wir auch weiterhin tun die
Ukraine muss unterstützt werden und wir
leisten unseren Beitrag dazu was glauben
Sie denn könnte Putin zum Einlenken
bringen
die Sanktionen die wir beschlossen haben
sie wirken sie machen deutlich dass wir
es ernst meinen auch dann wenn es die
eigene die eigene Länder betrifft und
mit dieser Geschlossenheit hat Putin
nicht gerechnet und damit natürlich auch
mit den Auswirkungen bei sich im Land
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir auf
diesem Weg auch bleiben glaubwürdig
diese Sanktionen zu durchzuhalten aber
eben auch die Ukraine zu unterstützen
aber daneben daneben ist es ganz wichtig
das verhandelt wird wie wir endlich ein
Waffenstillstand erreichen können und
beispielsweise auch humanitäre
Lieferungen möglich zu machen um
fluchtkorridore möglich zu machen und
deswegen muss an diesen Verhandlungen
weiter gearbeitet werden es gibt die
Verhandlungen Ukraine Russland und es
gibt viele zahlreiche Gespräche die das
ganze flankieren das ist das Gebot der
Stunde die Waffen müssen Schweigen
vielen Dank Frau Lamprecht nach Berlin
ich danke Ihnen
ja das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet live zugeschaltet
ist jetzt Generalleutnant ad-kasten
Jacobson was ist denn für sie das
wichtigste Ergebnis des
nato-gipfeltreffens heute
es war beeindruckend heute zu sehen dass
das was
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg gestern
angekündigt hat heute von 30 Staats- und
Regierungschefs übereinstimmend und mit
großer Kraft vorgetragen worden ist das
was wohl eines der überzeugendsten
Argumente ist dass wir das was wir seit
fünf Jahren tun nämlich Stationierung
von Truppenteilen über jeweils
halbjahresabschnitte in Estland Lettland
Litauen und Polen nun auch erweitern auf
Rumänien Bulgarien Ungarn und die
Slowakei und das hier alle Nato-Partner
starten an einem Strang ziehen und damit
im Prinzip die verfügbaren Truppen in
den östlichen Partnerstaaten verdoppeln
gleichzeitig waren natürlich die
Aussagen die getroffen worden sind zur
Unterstützung mit Waffenlieferungen und
zu Schutzmaßnahmen für die Ukraine
durchaus sehr stark und überzeugend aber
reichen denn die Kräfte wirklich aus um
die östlichen bünd Partner der NATO zu
schützen
nun sie sind ein klares Signal dass ein
Putin gesendet wird dass die NATO
einheitlich steht dass wir unsere
Bündnispartner verteidigen werden und
das ist sich hier um alle Nationen um
alle 30 Nationen der NATO handelt die
ein klares militärisches Signal setzen
mit hoher Verfügbarkeit und hoher
Bereitschaft wie groß ist denn für sie
die Gefahr dass die Krieg nicht auf die
Ukraine begrenzt bleibt
nun dazu gibt es klare Aussagen die
Entscheidung ob der Krieg auf die
Ukraine grenzt bleibt liegt letzten
Endes bei Puten die Nato hat klar und
deutlich gesagt wo die rote Linie ist
das ist die ostwärtige Grenze des
Bündnisses wenn er diese überschreitet
dann befindet er sich im offenen
Konflikt mit der NATO es ist also seine
Entscheidung dass die dass die Ukraine
unterstützt werden wird durch uns mit
Waffenlieferungen dass die Ukraine
unterstützt werden wird durch die
Weltgemeinschaft und wo die Meinung und
die Zustimmung der Welt liegt das haben
wir heute im in der Vollversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen gesehen
vielen Dank wir sprechen später noch mal
weiter zu der Situation in der Ukraine
ja die drei Gipfel heute die natürlich
auch dazu Russland gegenüber Stärke zu
demonstrieren Putin zu zeigen wie viele
Staaten gegen ihn stehen wie kommt das
in Moskau an Christian semberichtet
in den Nachrichten im russischen
Staatsfernsehen heute spielen die
Gipfeltreffen in Europa keine große
Rolle erstes Thema nicht ganz
überraschend Präsident Putin und sein
Treffen mit dem Sicherheitsrat lediglich
ganz am Ende der Sendung wird der
gipfelmarathon in Brüssel kurz
thematisiert stattdessen laufen den
ganzen Tag Bilder aus den Separatisten
Gebieten und der Südukraine nah der
besetzten Halbinsel Krim ein Reporter
will Beweise gefunden haben wie die
Ukraine hier Vorbereitungen getroffen
habe um die Krim anzugreifen wir fragen
die Menschen heute in Moskau was sie
über den Konflikt denken
ich beantworte keine kompromittierenden
Fragen
das ist im Prinzip schwer zu beantworten
wenn es der Präsident aber so für
richtig hält heißt das dass es nötig ist
wir persönlich denken ist reicht es ist
an der Zeit aufzuhören wir sind auch
gegen einen Krieg
das Staatsfernsehen ist vor allem bei
älteren Zuschauern in Russland immer
noch sehr beliebt
die Hauptaufgabe für das russische
Fernsehen ist ein bestimmtes Bewusstsein
bei den Menschen zu schaffen damit sie
den herrschenden Glauben schenken und
sie unterstützen genauso wie das
üblicherweise bei totalitären Regime der
Fall ist eine Kontrolle der
Informationen für die Loyalität der
Gesellschaft die Aufgabe der Propaganda
ist nicht etwas absolut Neues zu
schaffen sondern das bereits
existierende zu verstärken
für Verwirrung sorgt noch wo
Verteidigungsminister und putinfreund
Sergei gut steckt seit dem 11 märz ist
er nicht mehr öffentlich aufgetreten und
auch die Amerikaner beklagen dass sie
ihn nicht telefonisch erreichen können
Spekulationen über seinen
Gesundheitszustand machen im Netz die
Runde aus dem Kreml heißt es heute alles
in Ordnung scheugu habe wegen der
Ukraine viel zu tun und keine Zeit für
Termine
am Nachmittag wurde dann noch ein
Mitschnitt der Videokonferenz des
Sicherheitsrates heute veröffentlicht
Scholl GU soll auch daran teilgenommen
haben aber auf dem Video verschwindet
sein Bild plötzlich und taucht dann
wieder auf was die Diskussionen anheizt
ob das Video bearbeitet wurde und wo der
russische Verteidigungsminister ist aus
dem russischen Außenministerium heißt es
am Abend noch Richtung NATO mit der
Entscheidung das Regime in Kiew weiter
zu unterstützen bestätige das Bündniss
sein Interesse die Feindseligkeiten
fortzusetzen
tja wie kann man Wladimir Putin stoppen
der besten versucht es mit Sanktionen
wobei auch Deutschland bremst wenn es um
die Einschränkung von Öl und Gasimporten
aus Russland geht zu groß die
Abhängigkeit aber reichen die bisherigen
Maßnahmen aus und wie wirken sie ein
Überblick von Sebastian ehm
[Musik]
Russland das größte Flächenland der Welt
144 Millionen Menschen leben dort mit
einer Wirtschaftsleistung von 1,5
Billionen Dollar ist es die 11 größte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt
das Ziel der Sanktionen ist die
Schwächung Russlands die USA und die EU
aber auch Kanada Japan und Australien
wollen Russland auf vielen Gebieten
treffen
das soll auch dazu führen innenpolitisch
den Druck auf Putin zu erhöhen
[Musik]
die Sanktionen richten sich gegen die
Wirtschaft die USA kaufen keine Kohle Öl
oder Gas mehr aus Russland damit
entgehen Putin Einnahmen in
Millionenhöhe Deutschland hat zwar Nord
Stream 2 auf Eis gelegt zögert aber
Energieimporte komplett zu stoppen
westliche Airlines fliegen Russland
nicht mehr an Flugzeug Ersatzteile
werden nicht mehr dorthin geliefert und
überflugsrechte für russische Maschinen
nicht mehr gewährt
hunderte Politiker wie
Verteidigungsminister Schoigu und
Kriminal Oligarchen sowie deren
Familienangehörige wurden mit
einreisesperren belegt Geld das auf
Konten in der EU den USA oder
Großbritannien liegt teilweise
eingefroren Yachten Immobilien
Privatjets könnten beschlagnahmt werden
weitreichend sind auch die Maßnahmen auf
dem Finanzmarkt
zahlreiche russische Banken wurden vom
internationalen
finanztransaktionssystem Swift
ausgeschlossen VISA Mastercard und auch
Paypal haben sich aus dem russischen
Geldgeschäft zurückgezogen
außerdem wurden zu Beginn des Krieges
über 600 Millionen Dollar der
Währungsreserven der russischen
Zentralbank eingefroren
[Musik]
westliche Läden geschlossen lange
Schlangen vor den Geldautomaten Verfall
des Rubel doch noch scheint in die
Sanktionen Putin nicht zu schwächen noch
scheinen sie keine direkten Auswirkungen
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine zu haben
die Frage die man sich im Westen stellt
wie lange noch
und zugeschaltet ist mir nun der
ehemalige deutsche Botschafter in
Russland Rüdiger von Fritsch guten Abend
Fritsch können die Sanktionen Putin
wirklich stoppen
die Sanktionen die befeinigt habe oder
noch verhängen könnten sind nicht
geeignet diesen schrecklichen Krieg zu
beenden in seiner Kriegsführung ist
Russland weitgehend autark wenn die
Panzer nicht rollen hat es ja nicht mit
Benzinmangel zu tun sondern mit
schlechter Logistik aber diese
Sanktionen dass die klare Ankündigung
Wladimir potenziellen eben auf was
anderes sie erzählen darauf ihm an seine
Macht Basis zu gehen er ist dauerhaft
auf extrem hohe Einnahmen angewiesen um
sich die Zustimmung seiner Bevölkerung
zu kaufen und er weiß dass wenn ihm
dieses Geld ausgeht das ist dann
gefährlich für ihn werden kann er mag im
Moment offiziell eine hohe Unterstützung
im Lande haben aber wie mir ein
russischer Gesprächspartner einmal sagte
in dem Moment wo er strauchelt geht
keiner für ihn auf die Straße
ja was hören sie denn aus Moskau wie
stark treffen die Sanktionen die
Menschen im Alltag
also erstens erreichen mich und Freunde
und Bekannte verstörende und
schreckliche Nachrichten auch von
Menschen in Russland die eben furchtbar
betroffen sind entsprechend gar nicht
von der materiellen Situation sondern
auch von der Repression im Lande die
nicht einverstanden sind Menschen
inzwischen Russland verlassen haben die
um Hilfe bitten konkret im Alltag ist es
so dass die Sanktionen natürlich sehr
schnell die Menschen erreicht haben das
fing am ersten Tag an das ist in den
Geldautomaten nicht mehr unbedingt Geld
gab inzwischen gibt es auch gewisse
Versorgungsmängel Zucker Salz
Medikamente anderes hört man ist nicht
einfach zu vermuten ist dass die
Sanktionen insbesondere die Menschen in
den großen Städten Treffen werden wo
inzwischen ein anderes Lebens- und
Wohlstandsniveau herrscht wohin gegen
auf dem weiteren Land in den kleineren
Städten der Effekt noch nicht so
unmittelbar ankommt
diese drei Gipfel heute mit der
zelebrierten Geschlossenheit des Westens
beeindruckt das Putin
nun er muss zumindest feststellen dass
er in mehrfacher Hinsicht mit seinem
Krieg russlandsinteressen massiv
geschädigt hat nicht also entschädigte
eigene Wirtschaft er macht sich zum
Juniorpartner Chinas er hat die Ukraine
für alle Zeiten entfremdet und er hat
den Westen in seltener geschlossen hat
zusammengeführt was wir im Moment ja
sehen ist dass sich nicht die
internationale Ordnung ändert sondern
dass der russische Präsident sein Land
aus dieser Ordnung herausnimmt und der
Westen fest zusammen steht dass ein
wichtiges Signal und von solchen Treffen
gehen von daher entscheidende Signale
aus es ist auch wichtig dass die Staats-
und Regierungschef sich unmittelbar
miteinander besprechen Einschätzung
teilen weiteres verabreden und das
wichtigste allerdings mit glaube ich
auch ist dass die Europäer sich
zusammensetzen und sich überlegen wie
können wir sollten wir darauf angewiesen
sein eigenständig handeln zu müssen denn
erfolgreich vorgehen wenn es ja nicht
garantiert dass der Nachfolger von Joe
Biden nicht wieder George Trump sein
Donald Trump sein wird ganz gleich wie
heißen mag was sind denn für Sie die
wichtigsten Ergebnisse von heute
nun ein ganz wichtiges Ergebnis ist
sicher dass der NATO die beschlossen hat
die östliche Flanke weiter zu stärken
und damit beginnt die NATO sich mit
dieser Realität die Wladimir Putin
geschaffen hat auseinanderzusetzen wir
haben aber Jahrzehnte und Deutschland
besonders versucht Sicherheit gemeinsam
zu bauen er hat die Sicherheit
zerstört und wählt eine Situation der
Konfrontation damit hat er auch ein
wichtiges Abkommen zwischen der Nato und
Russland de facto zerrissen das
begrenzte wie viel Truppen auf jeder
Seite stehen dürfen das waren 1000
Soldaten pro Land das muss man immer
klar machen für die NATO das hat er
zerstört die NATO bereitet sich auf
diese Situation des gegeneinander vor
damit wir auch in Zukunft gut geschützt
werden herzlichen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Rüdiger von Fritsch
sein Ziel den schnellen Sieg in der
Ukraine eine Art Blitzkrieg gewinnen und
die Regierung selensky entmachten hat
Wladimir Putin nicht erreicht und je
länger der Krieg dauert desto mehr
Angriffe auf die Zivilbevölkerung gibt
es auf Krankenhäuser oder Schulen wie
weit wird Putin noch gehen
eindringlich warnte US-Präsident Joe
beiden vor einem Einsatz von
Chemiewaffen das seine echte Bedrohung
sagte er noch vor Ankunft in Brüssel die
Nato will jetzt ihre
Reaktionsbereitschaft verstärken über
die Gefahr von Chemiewaffen Martin
hornecker
Chemiewaffen eine unsichtbare Bedrohung
mit dem Nervengift novichog will das
russische Regime Gegner ausschalten 2018
entkommen der ehemalige Agent sergeys
grippal und seine Tochter Julia nur
knapp dem Tod
offenbar hat Russland noch Restbestände
des Nervengiftes aus sowjetszeiten zwei
Jahre später Anschlag auf Regimekritiker
naweini auch er überlebt die
novi-schock-vergiftung nur knapp seit
rund zwei Wochen werfen
russlandsvertreter im UN-Sicherheitsrat
der Ukraine immer wieder vor den Einsatz
von Bio und Chemiewaffen zu planen
wir sind sehr besorgt über die jüngsten
Entwicklungen Sumi und den anderen
Regionen in Bezug auf chemische
Provokationen inszeniert von den
ukrainischen Nationalisten
ein möglicher Vorwand um selbst
Chemikalien als Waffen einzusetzen und
den Urheber zu verschleiern eine
sogenannte forceflack-operation
Putin steht mit dem Rücken zur Wand und
kommt daher mit diesen
Täuschungsmanövern er behauptet wir
Amerika hätten biologische und chemische
Waffen in Europa
das ist einfach nicht wahr das
garantiere ich Ihnen und er behauptet
die Ukraine hätte biologische und
chemische Waffen für mich ist das ein
klares Zeichen dass er plant beides
einzusetzen
Experten halten den russischen Vorwurf
die Ukraine könnten Chemiewaffen
einsetzen ohnehin für unhaltbar
Einsatz macht technisch militärisch ein
gewissen Sinn gegen Leute die sich
eingegraben haben das wären die Ukraine
oder gegen Leute die sich vor nehmen wir
mal der Mann und dem Beschuss mit
Artillerie schützen wollen und dazu in
entsprechende Schutzräume gehen das
wären auch wieder die Ukraine das heißt
die Ukrainer würden sich selber
beschießen dass das macht also überhaupt
keinen Sinn das Russland größere
Bestände an militärischen Chemiewaffen
besitzt gilt als unwahrscheinlich denn
das Land ist Mitglied in der
Organisation für das Verbot von
Chemiewaffen die die Mitgliedstaaten
auch kontrolliert
allerdings könnten auch alltägliche
Industriegase wie Chlor als chemiewaffe
missbraucht werden dafür reicht ein mit
Chlor gefüllter Behälter abgeworfen aus
einem Hubschrauber so geschehen im
syrienkrieg in dem Russland den
Machthaber Assad stützt
Chlorgas ist heimtückisch es ist
schwerer als Luft trinkt selbst durch
kleine Ritzen und gefährdet so Menschen
unter der Erde etwa ein Schützengräben
oder Bunkern mit dramatischen
Konsequenzen und ist dann zunächst
natürlich auf die auf die Lunge wirksam
das heißt die Leute können nicht atmen
die kriegen entsprechende
Lungenschädigungen aber es reagiert auch
mit den Augen ist nicht eine ziemlich
scheußliche Angelegenheit wenn man
rauskommt kommt man raus wenn man nicht
rauskommt da steckt man einfach ein
Grund für die NATO Russland heute
eindringlich vor diesem Schritt zu
warnen
jeder Einsatz chemischer Waffen würde
die Art des Konfliktes fundamental
verändern das hätte weitreichende und
harte Konsequenzen
wie die aussehen könnten das bleibt
vorerst unklar
ja darüber sprechen wir noch mal mit
Generaloberst ade Carsten Jacobson wie
schätzen sie denn die Gefahr ein von
einem Einsatz von Chemiewaffen
genauer Leutnant vielen Dank für die
Beförderung entschuldigung es ist schon
bedrückend wenn man
es ist schon bedrückend wenn man erlebt
wie Russland in seinen lügenapparat und
Propaganda Mechanismen darauf hinweist
dass die Ukraine hier einen chemischen
Schlag oder biologische Waffen einsetzen
möchte wir haben dazu alles gehört was
gesagt worden ist aber es ist natürlich
so dass die Bedrohung damit in der Luft
steht dass die Bedrohung des Einsatzes
von Chemiewaffen durch die Russen die
sie im kleinen Jahr eingesetzt haben die
Beispiele sind gebracht worden und die
sie mitgetragen haben als sie in Syrien
eingesetzt worden sind und so macht es
Sinn die Ukraine hier zu unterstützen
mit Schutzbekleidung mit Ausbildung mit
medizinischer Ausstattung mit
Möglichkeiten sich darauf vorzubereiten
und zu üben dies ist mit Sicherheit eine
Sache die gut ist erforderlich ist um zu
verhindern dass derartige Waffen
eingesetzt werden im schlimmsten Falle
gegen Städte
wäre so ein Einsatz von Chemiewaffen
dann eine rote Linie die NATO doch
zwingen würde in den Krieg einzugreifen
wir haben es ja gehört die Nato hat ja
heute vor schwerwiegenden Konsequenzen
gedroht
Präsident beiden hatte zu ganz klare
Aussagen gemacht er hat gesagt es kommt
darauf an was dort passiert es ist auf
jeden Fall eine drastische Veränderung
des kriegsbildes und es ist auf jeden
Fall ein Kriegsverbrechen und verstößt
gegen alle Vereinbarungen die auch
Russland unterschrieben hat vielen Dank
Carsten Jakobson general Leutnant ARD
wir reden gleich weiter
doch nachdem wir so viel über die
Ukraine geredet haben wollen wir auch
ins Land schauen wie ist die Lage dort
vier Wochen nach dem Beginn des Krieges
ein Überblick von Gerd Anhalt
Gudrun
verließ wieder erfolgsnachrichten heute
morgen hat die russische Armee die Stadt
istium bei harkiff eingenommen erklärt
Moskaus Armeesprecher davor hätten sie
in der Nacht Einrichtungen der
ukrainischen Armee mit Präzisionsraketen
ausgeschaltet
aber nicht nur für seine Zerstörungen
feiert sich das russische
Verteidigungsministerium heute sondern
auch für seine humanitäre Hilfe 1000
Pakete mit Hilfsgütern hätten die
Soldaten in einem von Russen
kontrollierten Stadtteil Mario Polz und
das Volk gebracht Nahrung Strom und
Wasser haben die eingeschlossenen schon
lange nicht mehr wie zum hohen sind die
Pakete mit dem berüchtigten Z verziert
dem Symbol unter dem die Invasion steht
fluchtkorridore lassen sie weiterhin
nicht du aber sie machen die
verzweifelten zu Statisten ihrer
Propaganda
die bringen uns Brot und Windeln für die
Kinder wir
haben auch für das kleine Baby bekommen
Mario Paul die strategisch bedeutende
Stadt am Asowschen Meer widersetzt sich
weiterhin den Angreifern und ihrem immer
wütenderen Beschuss der Wohnsiedlungen
der Geschäftsstraßen in denen laut
Augenzeugen berichten hunderte Tote
liegen sollen
im Netz veröffentlichte Videos sollen
die Zerstörung der Innenstadt zeigen und
scheinen die Vermutung zu bestätigen
dass die Angriffe der Russen auf zivile
Ziele heftiger werden je größer ihre
Verluste sind
im Park neben dem Spielplatz bestattet
diese Frau ihren Stiefvater der schon am
12 März getötet wurde
er war verwundet und der Arzt und ein
junger Mann wollten ihn ins Krankenhaus
bringen dann wurde das Auto beschossen
wir konnten ihn erst jetzt begraben weil
nun der Boden nicht mehr gefroren ist
wenn stimmt das Russland zu Beginn des
zweiten kriegsmonats weitere Truppen
mobilisiert um die Angriffe noch zu
verstärken dann werden die Gräberfelder
hier und in anderen bedrängten Städten
wohl weiter wachsen
denn auch nach vier Wochen Dauerbeschuss
ist den Angreifer nicht gelungen
wichtige Städte wie harkev einzunehmen
wo bergungstrupps die Trümmer beseitigen
und in den Ruinen nach Blindgängern
suchen die noch detonieren könnten
auch in Kiew durchkämmen
Sprengstoffexperten der ukrainischen
Bundespolizei die attackierten
Wohnanlagen um zwischen splittern und
Mauerresten die immer noch
hochgefährlichen Sprengsätze zu finden
und unschädlich zu machen wenn sie etwas
Verdächtiges bemerken sollen die
Einwohner sofort die Behörden
verständigen wird immer wieder gewarnt
aber wer kennt sich schon aus mit den
vernichtungswerkzeugen einer
eroberungsarmee die plötzlich über den
Siedlungen niedergehen
besonders die Vororte im Nordwesten der
Hauptstadt lagen auch gestern wieder
unter schwerem Artillerie Feuer was den
Bürgermeister und seinen Bruder auf den
Plan rief die Klitschkos werden nicht
müde an den Durchhaltewillen ihrer
Mitbürger zu appellieren hier auf
Englisch damit die Welt es hören kann
ich als euer Bürgermeister sage euch
Bürgern und ich sage vor allem den
Russen eure Truppen werden hier niemals
einmarschieren ich würde eher sterben
als nieder Knien eher sterben als euer
Sklave zu sein wenn dieses Leben dieser
unbeugsamen Haltung haben sich nicht nur
viele Bürger sondern auch die Vertreter
der Künstlerszene Kiews angeschlossen
die in ihren Werkstätten nun
kampfausrüstungen anfertigen
Eisenplatten als kugelschutz
Öfen für die Unterstände Westen für den
Grabenkampf
wir kämpfen hier nicht nur um unsere
Freiheit Folgen es geht um unsere
Existenz deswegen habe ich nie daran
gedacht zu flüchten und ich bin froh
dass ich hier bin und etwas beitragen
kann
eiserner Zusammenhalt ein Gedanke den
auch der Präsidentin seiner jüngsten
Videobotschaft an das Volk wieder
aufgriff sie muss jetzt immer noch nach
einem Monat der Kämpfer haben wir sechs
Mal so lange Stand gehalten als die
Russen es uns zugetraut haben
sie dachten wir seien kein Staat sie
glaubten wir wären keine Nation sie
haben sich selbst was vorgemacht
das scheinen auch diese Aufnahmen zu
unterstreichen sie zeigen den Hafen von
bergjansk wo die ukrainische Marine ein
russisches Landungsschiff versenkt haben
will zudem sollen ukrainische Verbände
unweit von Kiew die Angreifer
zurückgedrängt und Gelände gut gemacht
haben
davon wird man bei Herrn konarschenkov
vom russischen Verteidigungsministerium
freilich nichts hören der hatte nur die
Eroberung von isium bei harkev zu
vermelden
wer diese Stadt im Internet sucht der
findet solche Bilder dazu Münster schon
vor 2000 Jahren der römische Historiker
tazitus die Worte sie schaffen eine
Wüste und nennen es Frieden
Jakobson an welchem Punkt sehen sie den
Krieg in der Ukraine vier Wochen nach
Beginn
ja das hatte sich die russische Seite
sicherlich ganz anders vorgestellt ein
schneller Einmarsch zwei drei Tage eine
schnellausweichende Regierung
aber die Regierung ist eben nicht mit
dem Taxi weggefahren sondern sie bittet
um Munition und Munition hat sie
bekommen und es ist bewunderungswürdig
wie die Ukraine in der Lage sind die
Waffen die Ihnen geliefert worden sind
panzerbrechende Waffen und Fluch
abwehrwaffen auch einzusetzen hier zeigt
sich dass es die richtige Entscheidung
ist ihnen die Systeme zu überlassen die
leicht zu bedienen sind die leicht zu
erlernen sind denn natürlich muss man
mit solchen Waffensystemen auch umgehen
können mit jedem Tag den dieser Konflikt
länger dauert steigt die Moral und die
Wut der Ukraine und lässt die Moral der
russischen Soldaten mit Sicherheit nach
bei den Bildern den sie sehen und bei
den Zahlen die sie erleben müssen und in
dem traurigen vorletzten Beitrag in dem
es um den gefrorenen Boden ging lernen
wir eine alte Lektion nach Väterchen
kommt in Russland Mütterchen Schlamm und
dann wird es für die Russen noch
schwerer ja was glauben Sie wie wird das
in der nächsten Tagen weitergehen
nun sie kommen gegen die Städte nicht
voran
ich vermute auch dass sie in die Städte
gar nicht hinein wollen in die inneren
Städte der in ein Häuserkampf würde für
sie noch viel schwerer werden als alles
das was sie bisher erlebt haben die
Kämpfe scheinen sich zunehmend zu
verlagern in den ostwärtigen Bereichen
um hier Tatsachen zu schaffen die dann
in Verhandlungen irgendwann ja kommen
müssen zu einer entsprechend guten
Position aus russischer Sicht führen und
vielleicht zu einer Position wo Putin
sagen kann seht ihr meine Lieben
Mitbürger eigentlich haben wir gewonnen
moralisch und zunehmend auch militärisch
haben sie jetzt schon verloren vielen
Dank Carsten Jakobson
wie erleben die Menschen in der Ukraine
den Krieg diese ständige Bedrohung
zwischen Bombenhagel und der Angst alles
zu verlieren Jennifer Gierke hat mit
Ukrainern gesprochen die alle versuchen
zu helfen
Juri ist Unfallchirurg und Orthopäde in
Kiel vor dem Krieg war er auf
Sportmedizin spezialisiert doch seit
vier Wochen versorgt der
Kriegsverletzungen seine Patienten meist
Zivilisten erfasst von tödlichen
Explosionen
jetzt gibt es keine russischen
Bodentruppen mehr nur Bombardement nur
Flugzeuge die Bomben abwerfen
[Musik]
das ist wie ein Glücksspiel wo die
nächste Bombe einschlägt
eine 24 Stunden Schicht nach der anderen
diese Arbeit geht an die Substanz seine
Frau soja ist mit den Kindern in den
Westen des Landes geflohen eigentlich
wollte er mit ihnen gehen aber sein
Pflichtgefühl war stärker
nach fünf Tagen bin ich wieder nach Kiew
zurückgekehrt hier werde ich gebraucht
hier ist meine Arbeit willst du das
auch er wird in Kiew gebraucht ein
freiwilliger der Bürgerwehr eigentlich
ist der Schauspieler war regelmäßig im
Fernsehen zu sehen jetzt will er nicht
mehr erkannt werden die Waffe mehr als
nur eine Requisite und sein altes Leben
seit dem 24 Februar vorbei
das war ein ganz normaler Wochentag am
Abend habe ich noch den Rollentext
gelernt um 7 Uhr am nächsten Morgen
sollte am Set gedreht werden gegen fünf
hörte ich die Explosionen ab dann war
mein schauspielleben zu Ende und alles
wandelte sich um 180 Grad in einer
Sekunde
nun wird er seine Stadt verteidigen
komme was wolle
wahrscheinlich sind wieder einige
geflüchtete gekommen und sie kriegen
gerade etwas zu essen sie sagen alle
Gott sei Dank weil sie überlebt haben
Hauptsache überlebt vor dem Krieg war
das ein Sommercamp für Teenies ein oder
150 Kilometer entfernt von Kiel jetzt
werden hier ein kräftete Ukrainer
versorgt als Zwischenstopp auf der
Flucht
die Mission des Camps ist es den
Menschen irgendwas Gutes zu geben etwas
das wir alle gerade vermissen einen
sicheren Ort an dem du dich beschützt
fühlst an dem du Liebe und Beistand
anderer spürst
[Musik]
viele der Helfer sind selbst aus ihren
Heimat Orten geflohen auch Olga sie ist
Managerin einer Sprachenschule in Kiew
trösten kochen putzen von früh bis spät
sind sie im Einsatz seit nun schon vier
Wochen
nach einem Monat sind wir alle sehr müde
und erschöpft manchmal manchmal
verlieren wir sogar den Glauben an den
Sieg aber wir beten weiter und bitten
Gott um diesen Sieg wir wollen alle
wieder zurück zu unseren Häusern und zu
unserem normalen Leben
bis es soweit ist machen Sie hier weiter
auch für solche hoffnungsmomente wenn
Kinder einfach Kinder sind und den Krieg
für einen Moment vergessen
ja wenn sie den Menschen in der Ukraine
oder auf der Flucht helfen wollen dann
können Sie spenden an das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Ukraine iban.de
6500 400 600-100 400 600 alle Infos auch
unter Spenden zdf.de oder im zdf-text
auf Seite 890
mehr als dreieinhalb Millionen Menschen
sind bisher vor dem Krieg geflohen über
zwei Millionen sind im Nachbarland Polen
die nächste Station morgen von
US-Präsident beiden bei seinem
Europa-Besuch über polnische Erwartungen
und die Situation der geflüchteten
Isabel de la Vega der Bahnhof von
schemische keine 15 Kilometer von der
ukrainischen Grenze entfernt es ist die
erste Anlaufstelle in Polen für tausende
Flüchtlinge die ihre Städte aus Angst
vor den Luftangriffen verlassen haben
vom amerikanischen Präsidenten beiden
erhoffen sie sich vor allem eins die
Schließung und Verteidigung des
Luftraums über der Ukraine durch die
Nato
und wenn sie den Luftraum nicht sperren
wollen damit es keinen direkten Krieg
zwischen Russland und dem Westen gibt
könnten sie doch andere Waffen liefern
damit wir das selbst machen können
Kampfflugzeuge oder irgendetwas anderes
die meisten hier kaufen Tickets um
weiter zu reisen in Richtung Westen doch
für einige wenige geht es die andere
Richtung diese amerikanische Ex-Soldat
will sich dem Kampf gegen Putin
anschließen er wartet auf einen Zug in
die Ukraine
ich erwarte von unserem Präsidenten dass
er als Anführer der westlichen Welt auch
militärisch Führung zeigt
Solidarität mit der Ukraine das ist in
chemische gelebter Alltag es ist ruhig
in der Grenzstadt doch keine 100 km
entfernt flog die russische Luftwaffe
bereits Angriffe
der Besuch beidens in Warschau ist
wirklich wichtig für uns vor allem
symbolisch es ist eine moralische
Unterstützung die zeigt wir lassen euch
hier nicht im Stich und falls es hart
auf hart käme werden wir zusammen Polen
verteidigen
weil Polen Mitglied der NATO ist fühlen
Sie sich hier sicher doch das Mitgefühl
für die Nachbarn ist groß und deshalb
auch die Erwartungen an die USA
die Ukraine brauchen mehr Hilfe aus dem
Westen mehr Waffen Flugzeuge was auch
immer
was auch immer aber in jedem Fall mehr
Militärhilfe um im äußersten Fall auch
das nato-gebiet im Osten verteidigen zu
können
ja und dann schalten wir zum Schluss
noch nach Brüssel zu unserem usa-kurs
von hinten Elmar the Wissen der
Präsident Joe beiden auf seiner Reise in
Europa begleitet immer Joe Biden hat
heute Abend ja auch eine Pressekonferenz
gehalten was war denn seiner
Hauptbotschaft
ja ich glaube ihm ist das Wichtigste das
Signal der Einigkeit weil es eben die
Grundvoraussetzung ist für etwas was ich
heute in all den Pressekonferenzen und
auch Hintergrundgesprächen abgezeichnet
hat nämlich ein neues strategisches
Konzept für die Herausforderung der
Zukunft Joe Biden ist ja der festen
Überzeugung wir sind in der großen
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den
Demokratien und autoritären Regimen
diese autoritären Regime nutzen ja ihre
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten von
anderen oder andere Staaten die von
ihnen abhängig sind zur Erpressung um
den Spaltpilz in die Bündnisse zu tragen
und jetzt hat das Bündnis der Europäer
der G7 und auch der NATO erkannt man
kann umgekehrt diese wirtschaftlichen
Abhängigkeiten eben auch nutzen um Druck
auszuüben um für die Menschenrechte und
für ein Ende des Krieges für den Frieden
einzutreten das funktioniert nur wenn
man sich absolut einig ist und
funktioniert auch nur wenn militärische
Stärke gegeben ist das wird einfließen
in diesen Dreisprung in die Strategie
der NATO die im Juni beschlossen werden
wird und ich glaube amerikanischen
Präsidenten heute das wichtigste gewesen
und was erwarten sie morgen bei seinem
Besuch in Polen
ja es ist auch mehr als nur ein Zeichen
der Solidarität wir erwarten dass er
sowohl US-Soldaten besuchen wird aber
dass er auch sich mit Flüchtlingen
trifft und auch das ein ganz wichtiges
Signal wenn es zu solchen Situationen im
Krieg kommt dass man die Staaten und vor
allen Dingen die Menschen nicht im Stich
lässt und auch das geht nur mit
Solidarität man muss beispielsweise
dafür sorgen dass Nahrungsmittel
Sicherheit besteht für die Zukunft
Energiesicherheit auch für die Menschen
und auch das geht nur in Bündnissen ich
glaube das ist das Signal was er morgen
eben auch in Polen senden will vielen
Dank Elmar Thesen
ja das war unser zdf-spezial heute zu
den drei Gipfeln in Brüssel die NATO
noch vor kurzem als hirntot bezeichnet
demonstriert Handlungsbereitschaft und
sendet deutliche Warnungen in Russland
mehr Informationen jederzeit auf ZDF
heute.de und später im heute-journal
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Lena
Lorenz auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]